hello and welcome to playstation grenade
it's time for another elusive target
this time is the blackmailer here in
Paris and if you haven't guessed already
this is hitman what we have to do we
have to get this encrypted memory stick
off this gentleman and of course we have
to kill him too we can spot him his
makeup should make this quite easy to
spot hopefully Walter Williams you are
going down right then let's do this okay
so what you need for this nothing
absolutely nothing just pick which suit
you want to wear and start from the very
first location what we're going to do is
take it indoors we are going to run it's
going to be some waiting in this level
but at this point we're just going to
run forward the plan is to get to the
other side of the catwalk to do that you
can either go through the basement or
you can go get the dr go invitation from
the bathroom and that's where i'm going
to go so through the right and here it
is on the first left here just on the
side someone has left their invitation
so we'll grab that and we're going to
run outside silly little garden party
and all the way around to the back door
no no no no no
I do have a thing for the Santa costume
breeze bloody fantastic right once you
reach these gentlemen here you must
assure your ideal or rather your
invitation if you don't say goodbye to
sound assassin suit only okay onwards
and upwards once you're in you want to
go past this guard but we can't go
without just run straight that we have
to go ground so get to this next door
we're going to turn left back on
ourselves don't worry about the person
behind us who conceals that was a
terrible run from me but usually you can
get past all right so do this guy so I'm
doing straight away don't not keep snap
his neck I did that by accident my first
time I played this drag him into this
bathroom and if for some reason you got
spotted don't worry as long as you move
that body quick enough you'll be fine
and most of you won't get spotted at all
it was a very terrible run that I
thought I'd show you the worst run
rather than the best run if it goes
wrong though you can just close the
application or you can restart the
mission depending on what happened so
keep that in mind ok so now we are at
the back of the catwalk but there's lots
of people who know who we are so you can
either hide behind this pillar or just
stand here like I am at the moment and
we're waiting for that gentleman we saw
with the this or cross of makeup and
will bloody hell is already here this
this is going to be a bit by the seat of
our pants so we're gonna do is gonna try
and knock into him first whilst is
throwing a party we're going to run to
the bathroom and we're going to turn on
the overflow think this is not quick
enough if you're quick enough here he
will hear this and common investigate if
you're not quick enough run back out and
just knock into him so remember to run
away again because people will recognize
you hopefully he will then yes there he
goes come and investigate this little
problem in the bathroom the Wet Bandits
have been here we're just going to stand
here and wait close the door if it
doesn't cause itself wait till he turns
off the sink that's very important then
just subdue him and when you get the
opportunity snap his neck pick up the
drive that's part of the mission dragged
his body into the wardrobe then picture
your exit so you can even go downstairs
but I'm not a fan
that so I'm going to go back i'm going
to retrace our steps that gentleman
still there who will look for us so yes
be quite quick through this room but
once you through there it's plain
sailing it really is just retrace all
your steps so once we're out with here
we're going to turn right back through
the party back through the the main part
of the mansion and through the front
door simple as that and they should give
us sounds assassin and it's not a great
run I could do this much better than
this but I prefer to show you a bad run
than a good run so we might get top 100
in the world if we look it or we might
be a long way off we'll see so through
here red cap it all the way out no one
knows it is Santa Claus is here no one
bothered I do love that Santa Claus for
the win and once you're at the exit that
should be it so anyways thank you very
much for watching please do as a massive
server and like and subscribe especially
so here subscribe bit we really need
your support to make our little channel
grow that was it I madelung from
PlayStation grenade and that was Santa
Claus suit only sound assassin elusive
target 19 I'll see you next time
[Music]